hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
the fortnight Island has kept updating
this week giving us the opportunity to
make a shot map change video so sit your
butt down for a few minutes
use code a tomorrow to keep this series
running and get through this lockdown in
one piece please
map changes season 2 chapter 2 week 10
let's do this without a doubt the
biggest news is my back bling guitar
it now has a green variant I don't know
how I feel about this so I need you to
help me decide do I stick with the pink
or do I switch to green on there's also
the purple one too
so help me make this choice do we stay
og pink do we switch to purple or do we
go green
[Music]
okay I'll get serious now without a
doubt the only place we can start is the
meteor in the sky if you're having
chapter 1 flashback so you're not alone
but this meteor is for a live event for
a Travis Scott concert over in sweaty
sands I'll be honest I had no idea who
he was and the first thing I googled was
this he fell off the stage I like him
already if you kept an eye on sweaty
sands you'll see a stage being
constructed right now this is what it
looked like a few days ago the
construction crews had moved in things
were being erected and now this is what
it looks like it still got a long way to
go but the biggest update are those
inflatable faces which if you jump on
them are very springy - there's more
construction to be completed but now we
have the dates and times for multiple
concerts by Travis Scott yeah the
posters around the island have updated
to show the times so check them out in
your country hopefully you can make one
of the shows I challenge you right now
if you can build hut wash during the
concert please upload a video and I'll
put it in this series next week
I wonder if Travis Scott knows about the
importance of hood watch well a change
which I missed five days ago which we
certainly need to talk about is the man
with the plan
the Ironman I did visit him last week
and saw no change at all but here's the
reason why the pipe wrench vanishes
whenever I get near why is that what are
you hiding from me epic pipe man now has
a golden pipe wrench but where could he
be going last update we talked about him
going to this location and maybe to the
shanty pipe structure here well once
again the replay files tell us more
there is indeed another pipe wrench just
here so we pretty much know that this
story is going to rival that of the rock
people from chapter 1 that story was
immense let's see if this one can be
just as impressive and as a side note if
this is a humanoid structure these
things here are his legs right then what
the hell is that bit in fact don't
answer that slice let's just move on
because we are family-friendly
over at the rig I missed a small but
very important change have you ventured
into this room lately for the last six
months the costume in the cabinet was
the venturi and skin from Chapter one
this was a callback to the sublime
season four story line including
superheroes
also in the room with some other cool
artifacts we'll talk about when they
become more important so many people
started playing in Chapter 1 season 4
those are happy days well right now that
costume has been updated to this there's
so many skins in the game now that I
completely have lost track of most of
them but to me this reminds me of the
tempest skin a person who was consumed
by the storm and returned to harnessing
that energy that's a call back story so
this could be a variant style of that
costume or could this be a new character
with new mystery powers let's keep an
eye on things if you've got a theory
throw it below as this is quite a short
episode I'm going to throw in some map
changes I haven't found a place for yet
for example do you remember the golden
toilet which appeared in season 1 on the
island the place that became the agency
well that toilet can now be found at the
waterworks by the dam hidden away behind
this wall the toilet is protected by one
of Graham's minions this is quite an old
update but I haven't ever covered it in
a video so I wanted to make sure we
documented everything as we go forward
and you never know if you haven't seen
it you have now and now we need to call
out a thief post boxes are going missing
another slow update happened to just
above pleasant Park in this house over
the course of season 1 & 2 the person
who lives in this house is stealing post
boxes from all around the island the
cold letterbox is over here in the UK or
they call where you come from most boxes
letter boxes mail boxes they're all the
same thing aren't they anyway we need a
name for this thief what would you name
the person stealing post boxes I'll be
lurking in the comments for the best
suggestion
so there's not enough here to talk about
for 10 minutes so let's just call the
episode an end there I won't waste your
time on screen now are the legends who
have supported this series in the
fortnight shop and sent me a DM on
Twitter with a picture of what they
purchased I then in return named them
here you sexy monkey fluffers how truly
appreciate you I'm currently working on
a story video for you and we'll get it
to you just after the Travis Scott event
ends I'm Adam from Playstation grenade
it's been an absolute pleasure I'll see
you next time
[Music]
note to self Adam put loads of videos of
Travis Scott falling off the stage in
this video oh yes yes indeed